[Musique]
c'est avec le coeur lourd que je vous
fais cette vidéo sur le dernier épisode
de game of thrones
il est vrai que c'est une série dont je
ne vous ai pas souvent parler sur la
chaîne seulement 2,3 théorie en
septembre et en octobre 2017
avant de reprendre avec cette fin de
saison 8 mais cette série je laime
d'amour et je pense de tout coeur qu
aucune série ne réussira à la dépasser
au fond de moi jamais une série ne va
procurer autant d'émotions de surprise
de rage et nous arrivons à son terme
je n'arrive vraiment pas à croire que la
série est achevée et j'aimerais vraiment
revenir sur la conclusion de ces huit
années d'histoire je tient réellement à
vous remercier quant à l'accueil de ma
vidéo sur ce que je pensais voir dans
l'épisode 6 un accueil que je trouve
très surprenant et auquel je ne
m'attendais pas j'ai eu faux sur
beaucoup de choses mais ce n'est pas
plus mal
les théories et les idées que je vous
propose servent à prolonger l'histoire
lui rendre hommage et l'enrichir du
mieux que nous pouvons nos viewer qui ne
sommes pas les show runner
ce dernier épisode de la série divise et
c'est tout à fait normal
comment réussir à conclure parfaitement
un succès international
je ne vous cache pas que j'ai attendu de
prendre du recul avant de vous faire
cette vidéo car je ressentais à la base
énormément de frustration mais la fin de
la série est comme ça et pas autrement
il nous faudra attendre les livres que
je vais commencer personnellement pour
connaître une autre potentiel fin pour
game of thrones
j'aimerais qu'ensemble nous revenons sur
certains points du dernier épisode de
game of thrones et la saison 8 en
général si possible je vous invite à
partager votre point de vue dans les
commentaires avec respect je lis
l'intégralité les commentaires et je
serai très intrigué de savoir ce que
vous avez pensé de cette conclusion
malheureusement si nous suivons l'ordre
chronologique de l'épisode
il va falloir commencer par ma plus
grosse déception concernant cette
conclusion je suis quelqu'un qui essaie
toujours de comprendre le message que le
réalisateur a voulu transmettre
mais ici c'est pour moi impardonnable
la mort de daenerys la saison manque
cruellement de développement et je suis
loin d'être le premier ni le dernier à
le dire mais justement cela gâche
réellement tout je ne le disait pas
spécialement vidéo mais daenerys était
mon personnage préféré dans la série
autant que jenny lannister le personnage
vous a montré une évolution fascinante
depuis la saison une et le fait qu'elles
s'éteignent au dernier épisode me
chagrine mais ça cela reste tout à fait
normal le problème plus tôt et que sa
mort est beaucoup trop négligé d'après
moi au point que j'ai été moins triste
que je ne pensais lettre l'idée pour moi
d'interrompre ce qui a été amené depuis
plusieurs années n'est pas acheté loin
là nombreux ont été ceux qui avaient un
rêve et qui se sont planté en beauté la
frustration ne peut être que présente
mais nous ne pouvons négliger la mort de
daenerys à ce point notamment concernant
le fait de briser la roue mais nous
allons y revenir dans la vidéo
j'en viens donc à l'ellipse que je
trouve très mal à mener et qui résument
pour moi une négligence scénaristique
est là la fin n'est pas douce amère mais
juste à mr la scène avec dragon était
phénoménale et c'était pour moi la plus
poignante de l'épisode drogon sait que
sa mère était aveuglé par le trône et la
conquête c'est ce qui la perdra
d'ailleurs mais est-ce que daenerys
était réellement folle ou simplement
trop emballé par sa victoire
le manque de développement de cette
saison 8 me laisse clairement sur ma
faim concernant la mer des dragons et sa
mort est trop rapide et presque
injustifiée de mon côté parce qu'elle
commence à devenir à extrême dans ses
idées elle doit être tué pour moi cette
saison 8 n'a pas été convaincante dans
le traitement du personnage incarné par
emilia clarke à mon plus grand regret
mais ce n'est que mon point de vue pour
en revenir à l'ellipse voici la grande
frustration que j'ai ressenti durant
l'épisode liée à la mort de daenerys
comment pouvons nous passer outre les
conséquences de la mort de daenerys
pourquoi ne pas avoir pris dix ou quinze
minutes pour montrer ce qui a suivi la
mort de la reine
nous devons
faire le deuil de la reine des dragons
j'aurais aimé voir vers gris en colère
contre john prête à le tuer et
l'enfermer dans une prison j'aurais aimé
voir thirion apprendre la nouvelle
depuis sa cellule et pleurer la mort de
la reine qu'il aimait et qu'il côtoya
malgré que ce soit lui qui est convaincu
john de le faire j'aurais aimé voir les
immaculés et les d'autres à qui rendre
un dernier hommage à leur reine nous
méritions de prendre le temps d'accepter
la mort de daenerys un personnage si
principal pour continuer voici enfin la
scène clé de l'épisode le poste ellipses
où nous retrouvons thirion enchaîné et
amener devant les seigneurs de westeros
et je ne peux m'empêcher de penser à ver
gris en premier effectivement avec du
recul la position de vers gris est très
délicate
ce dernier a perdu sa reine et se
retrouve à la tête des immaculés contre
toute attente daenerys a été tué par
john donc un traître pour les armées
ainsi que thirion qui a démissionné en
tant que main de la reine vers gris
n'est pas un politicien et encore moins
en ouest et rossi mais des choses
restent assez incohérente
ce dernier a toujours vécu pour daenerys
pour que sa reine triomphe et que son
objectif soit atteint
et malheureusement alors qu'il est en
position de force et était prête à tuer
des innocents pour la gloire de daenerys
ver gris accepte qu'un inconnu pour lui
entre guillemets prennent la place de
roy et décide à sa place de ce qu'il
doit faire
mais il faut que nous revenions à cette
fameuse ellipse qui cassent l'épisode
effectivement nous sommes sur une
ellipse de plusieurs semaines voire mois
après la mort de daenerys c soulignée
par la barbe de tyrion qui a bien poussé
tout comme celle de john snow
il est vrai que tout le monde en a marre
de la guerre et ver gris a probablement
eu le temps de faire son deuil et a
appris du monde de west eros est
justement cela aura été très intéressant
et important de voir vers gris faire son
deuil devenir le chef des immaculés et
comprendre qu'il doit aussi s'adapter et
en à peine cinq minutes des épisodes
nous avons un personnage prête à tuer
n'importe qui pour sa reine à quelqu'un
qui est prête à laisser le pouvoir à une
autre personne pour ensuite se ranger
c'est juste dommage quoi enfin bon il
est temps d'arriver au moment que je
pense vous attendez depuis le début de
la vidéo bran stark roi des six courts
bien que pour moi d'autres personnages
auraient pu devenir roi ou reine de
westeros je respecte ce choix qui semble
en quelque sorte
logique bien qu'assez peu convaincant
faut l'admettre effective membrane est
le dernier symbole mystique ou magique
si vous préférez de la série il est la
corneille à trois yeux est un personnage
très sage le discours de tyrion reste
juste et avec du recul j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas mais je suis sûr que
vous l'attendiez ce mais comme on
n'arrête pas de le répéter depuis le
début de la vidéo le manque de
développement casto et divise parmi les
fans concernant les choix des show
runner
il est très clair que la place du roi ne
peut être effacée du jour au lendemain
bien que la série avance vite
on ne peut modifier une société aussi
rapidement dans sa mentalité et les
normes instaurées
c'est donc légitime qu'il y est un
gouvernant mais c'est pas assez
développée pour comprendre ce choix
pourquoi crois tu que j'ai fait tout ce
chemin
c'est trop facile d'après moi j'avais
l'impression d'être face à dr strange
on peut facilement comprendre pourquoi
bras ne désirait pas la place de ses
nerfs de winterfell et pourquoi elle
raconta toute son histoire attirions
même si bran représente aujourd'hui
l'alliance de la royauté et de la magie
en y réfléchissant il ya un côté très
étrange à tous à branne qui ne désire
rien s'est laissé porter pour devenir
roi des six couronnes alors
effectivement cela reste assez implicite
mais il se peut qu'on ne puisse changer
l'avenir dans game of thrones est donc
bran ne souhaitait vraiment pas être le
roi mais cette phrase et je trouve très
mal à mener bran n'a rien fait il a
juste attendu
il a seulement placé les pions pour
défaire le roi de la nuit mais ça a faim
nous y reviendrons dans une prochaine
vidéo je souhaite rendre hommage au
night king j'accepte le fait que bran
soit roi en y réfléchissant c'était un
choix judicieux
mais qu'en est-il de daenerys
effectivement en tirions affirme que m
brasse en tant que roi est qu'à sa mort
un autre roi sera choisi permettra de
briser la roue mais c'est illogique le
fait le bran puisse engendrer de
descendance créera obligatoirement le
conflit à sa mort
quant à la reprise du pouvoir la roue
n'est pas du tout brisé je ne sais pas
si je suis très clair dans mes propos
mais au final tout ce qu'on aura
accompli daenerys n'aura rien changé
en quelque sorte et c'est là qu'on
arrive au moment le plus intéressant de
la série john sans que ce qu'il a fait
n'était pas c'est juste que ça rien n'a
été changé la roue continue malgré que
bran soit au pouvoir
john et la fin douce amère qui nous
avait été promis effectivement douce car
john est toujours en vie ainsi carrias
en deçà et bran la famille stark
néanmoins ce dernier est bannie et ne
retournera jamais dans le sud
john ne sera au final jamais roi alors
que ses origines lui donnait clairement
accès au trône personne ne connaîtra la
vérité est le protagoniste finira ses
jours au nord du mur en compagnie des
sauvageons le final concernant john snow
est réellement pour moi la plus réussie
on est content qu au final cela se
termine bien mais nous restons frustré
par rapport à ce qu'il a accompli et de
ne pas avoir plus du coup
malheureusement il y a trois grandes
faiblesses par rapport à cette fin qui
me perturbe beaucoup
tout d'abord jeunes de retour à la garde
de nuit n'est qu'un prétexte qui sert
surtout à faire plaisir à vert gris et
les immaculés
c'est ce qui est montré dans la série
sauf que vers gris souhaite aujourd'hui
aller sur l'île de nattes l'île de
naissance demi cndd est accompagné des
immaculés
ces derniers retournent dans la contrée
des sauces et n'ont que faire de ce
qu'il va se passer à westeros par la
suite c'est tout con mais une fois vers
gris partie pourquoi ne pas faire
revenir john snow pour qu'ils puissent
vivre avec sa famille john est un héros
de guerre et nombreux sont au fait de
ces actes et ce qu'il a accompli ce
n'est pas hier à qui dans l'épisode
symbolise la dernière partisans de
daenerys aux côtés de vers gris qui
pourra contester quelque chose même t on
a voulu se battre pour les stark et est
mort en star qu on ne peut ignorer tout
ce qu'a accompli john durant son
parcours il aurait fallu pour moi
souligné le fait que c'est son choix de
repartir dans le nord que john les voulu
même bran ne contestera rien et affirme
que tout ce qui devait arriver arriva
laissant son frère enfin son cousin
partir au loin alors qu'il devait avoir
la place du roi légitime
c'est presque à se demander si bran ne
voulais vraiment pas être roi en fait la
dernière faiblesse pour moi reste
varices et cela reste une question sans
réponse pour moi
varicent était le maître des chuchoteurs
toujours à rester dans l'ombre
en écoutant ce que ces petits oiseaux
lui répète
et avec ce final cela veut dire que
varicent a voulu commettre la trahison
envers daenerys sans se cacher ou sans
précaution derrière il l'a dit attirions
la main de la reine et même à john snow
lui même et après avoir tout avoué il
décide enfin d'écrire des messages et
les envoyer pour au final est brûlé je
ne comprends pas ce choix comment est ce
possible pour le personnage de varices
de faire ce genre d'erreur
malgré ces quelques déceptions je ne
peux détester cette série évidemment au
contraire je respecte les choix des
réalisateurs est-ce qu'ils ont amené
malgré ce qui semble pour moi être des
erreurs ou des incohérences
il n'y a pas de notion de mérite dans
game of thrones et la frustration est
donc de mise
mais il faut justifier pour moi ces
choix l'épisode n'est pas un fiasco ou
raté j'ai aimé le regarder mais je suis
attristé de certaines négligences qui je
pense aurait pu être facilement corriger
je ne pense pas spécialement revenir sur
pourquoi bran essaie de retrouver drogon
pour ceux qui se demanderaient je n'ai
aucune réponse en tête peut-être que
brown aimerait l'apprivoiser et le
contrôler pour au cas où il y aurait des
batailles à venir mais se serait-il
logique nous sommes normalement en paix
ou bien peut être retrouver la dépouille
de daenerys bref je ne comprends pas
bien la raison après tout il est vrai
qu'un dragon est précieux et utile nous
reviendrons sur la série très bientôt
je suis désolé si ma vision n'a pas plu
à certains je ne me permettrai jamais de
descendre une série ou un film
gratuitement
ce n'est pas mon but j'aime goat et je
voulais vraiment partager avec vous mon
ressenti sur le dernier épisode de cette
épopée de cette page qui se tourne dans
la pop culture
j'espère néanmoins que la vidéo vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
vraiment pas à vous abonner à laisser un
gros pouce bleus je me suis récemment
mis sur instagram pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient me suivre sur cette
plateforme
merci à jean guillot merci au cs merci j
à aurore martin
merci à toutes les personnes qui ont
constitué cette série emilia clarke je
t'aime [ __ ] je vais réellement avoir
du mal à passer à autre chose
nous avons clairement et efface un
chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma que le line up
soit avec vous cette et argo rock
[Musique]